sticking with China let's look at trust
and integrity the new buzzwords their
Beijing is promoting these values as it
rules out a nationwide social credit
system starting next years it's raised
eyebrows will receive though its own
citizens seem more open to the idea but
the system will keep track of people's
finances China doesn't have a good
consumer credit rating system for loans
but it will also monitor social media
activity online purchases and medical
records already partially in place in
some pilot cities this is taking Beijing
surveillance to a whole new level well
perhaps the government doesn't think so
they're excited about it and have
started marketing the plan including
with special pop songs targeting younger
citizens GW reporter Hong Stan Lee has
more on this house run tell us what
you've got
well sir China released a song named BS
cute as your word it features a few
Chinese popular Chinese idols and now
the song does not make direct reference
to the social credit system but in the
music video we can see a few new
technologies that are related to it
let's take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
so the main message of the song is to
tell someone to be a credible person but
there is an undertow in it actually
because of us we have seen in the music
video we are there are a men's store by
carrying and acts like borrowing books
from a library and these are things that
require one to have a good profile to
have a good credit
now speaking of good speaking of profile
we know we know that the social credit
system means that Beijing will keep
record of a citizen's or under one
single system and so the record will
probably affect the way that people can
use the services that we have seen in
the music video and also it's been
released under the guidance of
government authorities so it's really
promoting the system in a very subtle
way now has the Chinese government done
other campaigns like this for with with
all those pop music and stuff yes it has
so just this year's state news agency
Xinhua released a hip-hop song praising
Chinese achievements and yeah so we
should have a listen as well because it
is about the biggest Chinese political
event of the year two sessions
[Music]
well so this is just another example of
how China's propaganda can look like
today Hong Shen thank you very much